C'est une page sombre
et honteuses de notre histoire.
Celle de la France collaborationniste,
du régime de Vichy,
et du maréchal Pétain de 1940 à 1945.
Aujourd'hui encore,
Vichy abrite un secret bien gardé.
Un secret qui dormait dans les archives
depuis plus de 70 ans,
et qui se cache derrière
un nom insignifiant.
Le service des contrôles techniques.
Le non service des contrôles techniques,
ça cachait un peu l'activité.
Service des contrôles technique,
S.C.T.
Trois Lettre qui dissimulent une
incroyable histoire d'espionnage,
une vaste opération d'écoute
et de lecture de courriers,
dont a été victime la population
française dans son ensemble.
C'est la seule fois dans l'histoire
de France qu'il y a eu un espionnage,
de la vie privée des Français
à une telle échelle.
Vous avez 2 millions de lettres
à peu près qui sont lues tous les mois.
Objectif de cet espionnage
à grande échelle,
connaître les pensées
secrètes des Français
et surtout aider le Maréchal Pétain
à gouverner.
Gouverner, c'est savoir et donc quand
on a la possibilité d'entrer,
dans le courrier des gens et dans
leur intimité, dans leur secret,
c'est un moyen formidable.
Le secret était d'autant mieux camouflé
que le S.C.T ne s'est pas contenté,
de jouer les instituts
de sondages occultes.
Il est devenu une terrible
machine à broyer.
Pendant les 4 années d'occupation,
les contrôles techniques,
ont livré une chasse aux opposants
et surtout aux juifs.
Le service des contrôles techniques est un
instrument de la police politique,
qui est mise en place par l'Etat. C'est une
arme de destruction policière massive.
Aujourd'hui, 70 ans après les faits,
on prend tout juste la mesure
des ravages provoqués par le S.C.T.
Pour cela, il a fallu le travail
d'enquête d'un historien, Antoine Lefébure.
Après des années de recherches,
il est parvenu à établir que le S.C.T,
a joué un rôle clé
dans la répression sous Vichy.
Toute la partie répressive,
il fallait chercher pour la trouver,
on ne savait pas que ça existait.
J'avais cette idée a priori
donc j'ai fini par trouver.
Raconter l'histoire du S.C.T,
c'est entrer dans les entrailles de Vichy,
pour comprendre l'une des facettes
les plus noires du régime collaborationniste.
Une plongée au cœur de la répression
et de la psychologie d'un homme,
Philippe Pétain,
obsédé par la maîtrise du pouvoir,
et le contrôle total
de la population française.
10 Mai 1940.
Neuf mois après le début
de la deuxième Guerre mondiale,
les chars allemands enfoncent la défense
française dans les Ardennes.
Une offensive éclair après
de longues semaines d'immobilisme.
Alors que les Pays-Bas
et la Belgique ont capitulé,
l'armée française,
la plus puissante du monde,
ne peut résister
au rouleau compresseur allemand.
Le 14 juin, les nazis entrent dans Paris.
Devant l'ampleur de la catastrophe, le
gouvernement Paul Reynaud démissionne,
et appelle le maréchal Pétain
à la rescousse.
Lui, le héros de la Grande Guerre,
paraît être le seul en mesure
de sauver le pays de la défaite.
Les Français placent
tous leurs espoirs en lui.
Le maréchal Pétain,
c'est le vainqueur de Verdun.
C'est un homme âgé.
Il est né en 1856.
Qui fait donc figure un peu de sage.
Beaucoup de Français le considère
comme un protecteur,
comme le protecteur de la population.
Mais contre toute attente,
l'homme qui devait sauver la France,
l'engage à reconnaître sa défaite.
Le 17 juin, le maréchal
demande l'arrêt des combats.
C'est la stupéfaction !
Un armistice est signé à Rethondes,
Quatre jours plus tard.
Il prévoit l'occupation des deux tiers
du territoire par les Allemands,
au nord et à l'ouest.
Au sud, dans une zone dite "libre",
les Français conservent
un semblant de souveraineté.
Pétain et son gouvernement s'installent
dans la petite ville de Vichy,
devenue capitale provisoire du pays.
Le 10 juillet, les parlementaires
votent les pleins pouvoirs au maréchal,
qui s'autoproclame
chef de l'État français.
Dans la foulée, Pierre Laval,
jusque là sénateur,
est nommé vice président du Conseil,
soit numéro deux du nouveau régime.
Avec Laval et quelques fidèles,
à 84 ans, le maréchal décide d'entamer le
redressement de la France,
autour des valeurs :
Travail, famille, patrie.
Deux mois plus tard, en octobre 1940,
Philippe Pétain rencontre Hitler à Montoire.
Le chef de l'Etat promet au dictateur
nazi de collaborer avec lui.
Pour les Français, c'est un choc.
C'est librement que je me suis
rendu à l'invitation du Führer.
Une collaboration a été envisagée
entre nos deux pays.
J'en ai accepté le principe.
Quand Philippe Pétain, après avoir
rencontré Hitler à Montoire,
décide de s'engager dans
la voie de collaboration,
toute une partie de l'opinion
publique décroche.
Précisément parce que l'espérance
que le Maréchal prépare la revanche,
l'espérance que le maréchal soit
de mèche avec le général de Gaulle.
Cette espérance est,
dans une certaine mesure, bafouée.
Philippe Pétain en a conscience.
Il sait l'adhésion à sa politique
de collaboration fragile.
Jusqu'où peut-il aller ?
Sur quelle partie de la population
peut-il compter ?
Derrière les acclamations et les sourires,
combien d'hommes et de femmes
sont vraiment prêts à marcher,
main dans la main avec les Allemands ?
Combien accepteront le projet
de renouveau de la France ?
Pour gouverner sereinement,
le Maréchal a besoin de le savoir.
Mais dans un régime autoritaire
qui tourne le dos à la démocratie,
le chef de l'Etat n'a plus aucun moyen
de connaître les pensées des Français.
D'habitude, le pouvoir
connaît l'opinion publique,
car la liberté de la presse permet
à chacun de s'exprimer, de critiquer,
de dire ce qui ne va pas,
ce qu'on souhaite...
Plus de presse libre, fini !
D'habitude, vous avez les enceintes parlementaires,
il n'y a plus
de représentation parlementaire,
les mairies n'existent plus.
Quand un maire déplaît au régime,
il est renvoyé,
et remplacé par ce qu'on appelle
une délégation spéciale.
Ce qui veut dire que le régime
de Vichy est aveugle,
quant au sentiment de sa population.
Or, on ne sait jamais
comment une population peut évoluer.
Est-ce qu'une population ne peut pas
soudain s'embraser, s'insurger ?
Connaître l'opinion publique est une
question de survie pour le régime.
Puisque tous les capteurs qui permettent
de sentir le pouls du pays sont brouillés,
Philippe Pétain va employer
les grands moyens.
Il va espionner la population.
Un espionnage massif
lors duquel le maréchal,
va faire lire le courrier des Français
et écouter leurs conversations téléphoniques.
Jusqu'à preuve du contraire, c'est
la seule fois dans l'histoire de France,
qu'il y a eu un espionnage de la vie
privée des Français à une telle échelle.
Vous vous rendez compte,
vous entrez dans l'intimité,
vous ouvrez un courrier,
vous entrez par effraction,
si j'ose dire, dans la vie des gens.
Qui ne s'en doute pas.
Cette idée d'espionner la population
ne sort pas de nulle part.
Pétain s'appuie sur un service
de l'armée déjà existant,
qui a fait ses preuves avant lui.
Le contrôle postal.
Ce service, activé lors de chaque conflit,
permet à l'armée de prendre connaissance
du courrier échangé par la population.
Il a surtout pris une dimension inédite
lors de la Première Guerre mondiale.
Dès 1915, toutes les lettres rédigées
ou reçues par les soldats,
sont lues par des militaires.
L'objectif est d'éviter la diffusion
d'informations contraires,
aux intérêts de l'État.
Les informations qui vont être recherchées
vont être les informations tactiques,
concernant des déplacements de troupes
à venir ou concernant des opérations,
que l'État ne souhaite pas
voir connues de l'arrière.
Et donc les gens reçoivent les lettres,
elles sont censurées comme on dit.
Les passages qui ne devraient
pas figurer dans ces lettres,
sont encrés de noir pour
qu'on ne puisse pas les lire.
Les réflexions des poilus sur l'horreur
de la guerre, le récit de leur quotidien,
avec la mort, les obus, la boue,
les rats sont eux aussi censurés.
Le moral des troupes
est l'autre priorité,
car une guerre se gagne aussi à l'arrière.
Le contrôle est maintenu jusqu'en 1919,
puis disparaît comme il était apparu,
une fois la situation normalisée.
Lorsque le conflit éclate en 1939,
le contrôle postal est aussitôt réactivé.
Comme en 1914, des millions de lettres
sont épluchées chaque semaine,
et marquées au nom de la censure.
Avec le développement du téléphone,
les conversations sont à présent
elles aussi écoutées.
Pour cela, des militaires travaillent
aux côtés de demoiselles du téléphone,
qui sont chargées de relier
les abonnés entre eux.
Effectivement, deux correspondants étaient
obligés de passer par une personne,
qu'on appelait l'opératrice,
les demoiselles du téléphone,
qui établissaient la communication.
L'opératrice attrapait un cordon,
rentrait une fiche dans un trou,
et était en relation avec le demandeur,
qui lui disait je voudrais
tel numéro à tel endroit.
Donc l'opératrice avec son autre cordon
mettait une fiche dans un jack,
pour acheminer la communication.
Au mois de janvier 1940,
alors que la France et l'Allemagne
se regardent toujours en méfiance,
sans se livrer aucun combat.
Georges Volatron, un instituteur
de 32 ans, est appelé sous les drapeaux.
Il est affecté au service
de la censure postale.
Installé dans un bureau de poste,
Georges découvre l'étrange travail qu'il
doit effectuer pour le compte de l'armée.
Dès qu'une conversation
lui semble intéressante,
il a pour ordre de la noter
sur son carnet.
Si c'était pour raconter que le gamin avait
pleuré toute la nuit, ça ne l'intéressait pas.
Ce qu'il voulait savoir, c'est ce que
les gens pensaient au fond d'eux,
sur la conduite des opérations,
sur les événements.
Après la défaite de juin 1940,
George Volatron comme une partie
de l'armée et démobilisés.
Mais la censure postale ne va pas
disparaître pour autant.
Car au lieu de la dissoudre,
le maréchal prend une décision qui
va peser lourdement sur les populations.
Il va transformer la censure postale
en un service d'espionnage civil.
Un changement radical qui s'effectue
au mépris des libertés individuelles.
En l'espace de quelques semaines,
l'ancienne censure militaire,
va devenir un organisme ultra secret.
Entièrement dévolu au chef de l'Etat,
et ayant pour seul but de l'aider
à se maintenir au pouvoir.
Puisque Vichy est souverain dans sa zone,
et que ce nouveau service
ne les menace pas,
les Allemands laissent faire.
La nouvelle arme du régime
s'intitule S. C. T.
Service des contrôles techniques.
Un nom austère, délibérément neutre,
afin de ne pas éveiller les soupçons.
Dès l'été 40, en toute discrétion,
les premiers agents sont recrutés.
Il s'agit d'hommes et de femmes
venant d'horizons très divers.
Jusque là, ils étaient secrétaires,
comptables ou bien employés de bureau.
Les voici affectés à des postes de
contrôleurs ou d'inspecteurs,
et de dactylos pour les femmes.
En lisant leur fiche, on comprend qu'ils
se retrouvent là un peu par hasard.
Comme cette étudiante en philologie
et aide bibliothécaire,
que rien ne prédestinait à un tel travail.
Il y a des gens qui étaient des braves gens,
des braves soldats de réserve...
Qui se sont retrouvés à faire un travail
d'espionnage des populations.
Les temps sont durs.
Les prix des denrées
alimentaires flambent,
il est toujours bon d'augmenter
sa pension ou sa retraite,
avec un petit travail supplémentaire.
Comme les espions, les employés
du S.C.T Sont astreints au secret absolu.
Jamais ils ne doivent mentionner l'existence
de leur travail, même à leurs proches.
Pour tout ceux qui seraient tentés
de parler, les sanctions sont dissuasives.
Ils savaient que la moindre indiscrétion,
pouvait être punie par des peines très graves.
N'oublions pas qu'on est
dans une situation d'exception,
donc il risquait vraiment la prison,
et pas pour quelques jours.
En zone sud, seule où elles opèrent,
les commissions de contrôle
quadrillent le territoire.
Elles sont présentes dans toutes
les grandes villes comme Lyon ou Marseille,
mais aussi dans de plus petites,
parfois totalement inattendues,
comme Foix ou Montluçon.
Rapidement, près de 5000 agents travaillent
pour les contrôles techniques.
Ils sont installés dans les bureaux de poste
et prélèvent du courrier secrètement.
Par rapport à l'époque où l'armée opérait
le contrôle, les méthodes ont changé.
Plus aucune marque de censure
n'est visible.
Fini le tampon et le caviardage.
Les agents ne doivent laisser aucune
trace de leur surveillance.
Les ouvertures de lettres
se font en catimini.
Pour décacheter les enveloppes,
c'est le système D.
Les agents ont bricolé des appareils qui leur
permettent d'ouvrir le courrier à la vapeur.
Une lettre sur dix en moyenne
et contrôlée, au hasard.
Les lecteurs écouteurs ont développé
un espèce de sixième sens,
et ils sentaient quand une lettre
avait l'air d'être intéressante,
une enveloppe un peu épaisse,
une écriture élaborée.
Si l'agent juge un courrier
digne d'intérêt,
il est transmis à une dactylo
qui le recopie intégralement.
Fautes d'orthographe comprises.
Les lettres sont ensuite replacées
dans leur enveloppe,
recollées au fer à repasser, puis
réexpédiées incognito à leur destinataire.
Quant aux conversations téléphoniques,
elles sont écoutées par des agents qui
enregistrent tous les échanges prometteurs,
sur un drôle d'appareils qui n'est
autre que le tout premier dictaphone.
Faut pas imaginer des bandes
magnétiques et des cassettes.
On grave des sortes
de petits rouleaux, de cylindres,
qui gravent le son comme pour la musique.
Ensuite des dactylographe transcrivent
ces conversations téléphoniques.
Très vite, la surveillance du S.C.T
s'opère à une échelle industrielle.
25 000 conversations téléphoniques
et 2 millions de lettres,
sont interceptées chaque mois.
Pour atteindre un tel rendement,
le S.C.T a du forcer la main de la Poste,
et faire d'elle sa complice.
Pour cela, l'administration postale a été
contrainte d'enfreindre ses principes.
Lire le courrier dans le dos des gens
est contraire à son éthique.
Depuis la Révolution française,
les postiers doivent prêter serment,
et respecter le secret des lettres.
Le viol du courrier est un délit
puni par la loi.
La Poste ou les PTT,
de manière plus générale, face au contrôle
technique, c'est un véritable embarras.
S'il y a un secret postal,
pour eux, c'est sacré.
Sauf que quand leur gouvernement dit :
"Il n'y a plus de secret postal,
parce que c'est la crise, parce que
c'est la guerre..." Ils obéissent.
Donc La Poste était un collaborateur
forcé des contrôles techniques,
ce n'était pas du tout sa mentalité,
ni son plaisir,
mais un collaborateur
tout de même efficace.
Car depuis l'arrivée de Pétain, l'ensemble
de l'administration est aux ordres.
Elle n'est plus tournée vers l'intérêt
général mais vers celui du maréchal.
La Poste n'échappe pas à la règle.
Comme les autres fonctionnaires, les postiers
ont prêté serment au maréchal Pétain.
Depuis l'été 40, ils sont aussi sommés
de jouer les VRP du régime.
La Poste est utilisée par le régime
de Vichy, bien évidemment.
On se souvient, pour ceux qui l'ont vécu,
on a encore les images
des calendriers de la Poste,
avec les effigies de Pétain, des timbres
poste à l'effigie de Pétain.
Et donc il y a une diffusion
d'information qui se fait,
bien entendu par les moyens de la Poste
à la gloire du régime de Vichy.
Afin de protéger le S.C.T,
Vichy exige de plus de la Poste,
qu'elle dissimule l'existence
des contrôles techniques.
Or, les commissions de contrôle sont
installées au sein même des bureaux de poste.
Certains postiers ont des doutes.
Ils voient bien que des sacs
de courrier sont prélevés.
Et puis...
Qui sont ces drôles d'employés qu'il
croise parfois dans les couloirs ?
Dans les bureaux de poste, le bruit court
que le gouvernement espionne les Français.
Mais les PTT ont reçu un ordre express,
les contrôles techniques ne doivent jamais
être découverts par le grand public.
Si un jour les Français venaient à apprendre
que leurs correspondances sont épiés,
ils cesseraient de se parler librement.
La surveillance perdrait
alors tout intérêt.
Pour éviter les fuites,
le gouvernement de Vichy,
met donc la pression sur son personnel.
Et il n'hésite pas à utiliser la menace,
comme le montre cette note envoyée
par le secrétaire d'Etat aux PTT,
à tous les directeurs régionaux
de zone sud.
"Je vous prie de vouloir bien rappeler
aux agents de tout grade,
que l'activité de ces organismes doit
être entourée du secret le plus absolu.
Les manquements qui viendront à la
connaissance de l'administration,
feront l'objet de peines
disciplinaires très graves,
pouvant aller jusqu'à la révocation.
Les postiers sont donc prévenus.
Silence et bouche cousue.
Alors, éventuellement, ils font des
confidences à leur famille, c'est possible,
mais sinon, effectivement,
ça ne s'ébruite pas.
Vous n'allez pas écrire
au Nouvel Observateur ou à Libération,
pour raconter ce qui se passe,
pour le dénoncer.
Il faut quand même imaginer
qu'on vit dans un pays,
complètement étouffé
du point de vue des libertés.
Beaucoup de fonctionnaires
craignent pour leur poste,
parce qu'ils n'imaginent
pas pouvoir désobéir à un régime,
qu'ils considèrent comme légal,
à défaut d'être légitime.
Et donc, beaucoup de fonctionnaires
vont tout simplement obéir aux ordres.
En les menaçant de sanctions,
Vichy obtient le silence des postiers.
Le S.C.T peut opérer en toute tranquillité.
C'est ainsi que les contrôles techniques,
vont devenir un outil stratégique pour
Philippe Pétain et la boussole du régime.
Depuis qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir,
le maréchal est persuadé
qu'on lui ment afin de le flatter.
Il cherche désespérément à obtenir
des retours objectifs sur sa politique.
Les préfets ont bien pour mission de lui
remettre des rapports sur l'état de l'opinion,
mais ces derniers lui semblent suspects.
Ils lui seraient trop favorable.
Le maréchal va alors s'appuyer sur des
rapports qu'il commande au S.C.T,
et qui lui arrivent toutes les semaines.
Grâce à eux, le chef de l'Etat
peut adapter sa politique,
à l'opinion en temps réel.
Car dans leur lettre ou au téléphone,
les Français parlent avec franchise
de tout ce qui les préoccupe.
Des témoignages bruts dans lesquels
les craintes et les espoirs,
apparaissent au grand jour.
Un instantané des états d'âme des Français.
"Je suis bien ennuyé. On brouille
tellement la radio de Londres,
que la patronne s'agace
et ne veut plus me laisser écouter."
"L'attente est le plus grand des maux
et nous vivons dans l'attente."
"Si l'Allemagne gagne et reste puissante,
cette collaboration sauvera
ce qui peut être sauvé."
Grâce à ses interceptions
dont il reçoit des extraits,
le chef de l'Etat peut enfin lire
dans les esprits des Français,
comme dans un livre ouvert.
Ça valorise une fois de plus le fait
que l'information est une arme.
L'information est un élément qui va permettre
d'éclairer la prise de décision.
Et plus on pourra collecter d'informations,
plus on pourra prendre des décisions,
les plus opportunes possibles.
À en croire leurs conversation, le principal
sujet de préoccupation des Français,
est leur quotidien.
À l'heure où les files d'attente devant les
magasins, s'allongent chaque jour un peu plus.
La population est tenaillé par la faim.
Le régime de Vichy tente de faire
face en organisant un ravitaillement,
et en distribuant
des tickets de rationnement.
Mais cela ne suffit pas.
De nombreuses lettres interceptées
puis recopiées par le S.C.T,
laissent apparaître
des Français désabusés,
ne s'en sortant que grâce au marché noir,
comme ce correspondant écrivant
de Marseille à un couple d'amis parisiens.
"Au point de vue rationnement,
la situation est toujours mauvaise.
Pour l'améliorer, il nous faudrait beaucoup
d'argent et un autre caractère.
Nous ne pouvons profiter que
des petites combinaisons entre voisins,
et de temps à autre,
des amis mieux placés,
nous font bénéficier de quelques avantages.
Nous sommes très maigres
mais pas encore malades."
Il y a deux sujets majeurs qui reviennent
dans le courrier qui a été intercepté,
c'est d'abord le ravitaillement.
C'est un problème constant
pour les Français pour se nourrir,
même dans des lettres
où ils parlent d'autre chose,
le sujet du ravitaillement, de ce qu'ils
ont mangé ou pas, revient tout le temps.
Deuxièmement, c'est la lourdeur
et les difficultés de l'époque,
ils parlent énormément
de toutes les contrariétés.
Et la principale est le fait
qu'il y ait des prisonniers.
Et chaque famille avait
un prisonnier en Allemagne.
Mais pour Pétain,
la vraie raison de cet espionnage,
est d'avoir des retours sur sa politique.
Sur son choix de collaborer avec les
Allemands, bien sûr, mais pas seulement.
À l'été 1940, le maréchal a engagé ce
qu'il appelle une révolution nationale.
Un vaste programme idéologique
qui doit transformer le pays en profondeur.
Pour cela, le maréchal entend rompre
avec les idéaux républicains,
qui auraient causé tous
les malheurs de la France.
Son idée, c'est que la France, depuis
la Révolution, est entrée en décadence.
La Révolution nationale, donc,
qui est une entreprise réactionnaire,
au sens propre du terme,
qui vise à revenir,
à un ancien régime qui
est un ancien régime mythifié.
Pour ce faire, il faut éliminer
de la communauté nationale,
tous les éléments qui troublent son harmonie :
Les juifs, les communistes,
les francs maçons, les métèques.
L'exclusion d'une partie de la population
fait partie du programme de Vichy.
Mais comment les Français
vont-ils le prendre ?
Sont-ils prêts à s'engager
dans une telle voie ?
Les notes du S.C.T apportent
des éléments de réponse tangibles.
Et le moins qu'on puisse dire,
c'est que les retours ne sont pas
toujours très favorables à Pétain.
Si au début de l'occupation,
les Français acceptent la politique
de Vichy sans sourciller,
au fil du temps,
beaucoup la prennent en horreur.
Cette lettre envoyée en novembre 1941
par une jeune femme à l'une de ses amies,
montre bien l'aversion que certains
commencent à éprouver pour le régime.
"Parle moi de la fameuse devise
"Travail, famille, patrie".
Quel travail ?
Celui qu'on fait pour les Allemands ?
Quelle famille ? Dispersés,
les uns prisonniers,
les autres séparés par la ligne
de démarcation ou emprisonnés.
Quelle patrie ? Le grand Reich allemand
dont nous sommes les esclaves ?"
Les Français attendaient un bénéfice
de la collaboration,
ils ne l'obtiendront jamais.
Voilà pourquoi, progressivement,
ils perdent confiance,
et se détournent du régime de Vichy.
Considéré comme hautement stratégique,
les notes de synthèse qui recueillent
les pensées des Français,
sont estampillées secret.
Elles sont réservées aux hautes
personnalités du régime.
Pétain, le chef de l'Etat,
Laval, le vice président du Conseil,
certains ministres
et les préfets de région.
Toutes commencent par une même rubrique
intitulée "Menées antinationales."
Qu'est-ce qui est antinational ?
C'est tout ce qui est hostile.
Parfois même seulement indifférents
à la révolution nationale.
Donc les gens qui ne font
pas confiance au gouvernement,
qui n'apprécient pas sa politique...
Tout ça est regroupé sous le terme
"menées antinationales".
On trouve par exemple des partisans
du général de Gaulle,
parti à Londres continuer les combats.
Accusé de faire de la propagande.
Antinationaux aussi, les communistes
distribuant des tracts.
Même le fait d'écouter
des radios étrangères,
est considéré comme
une activité antinationale.
Au fil des mois, les synthèses
deviennent de plus en plus précises.
Et classent les préoccupations
des Français par thèmes.
On trouve par exemple
l'optimisme, la confiance,
mais aussi la réprobation à l'égard
de la politique du gouvernement.
Pour donner le ton, des extraits
de lettres sont mises en avant.
"Il faudrait bien que cela finisse
car on en a plus que marre."
"On vit dans une anxiété croissante."
"La politique sociale du gouvernement
est bien mal dirigée."
Avec le S.C.T, le contrôle des pensées
secrètes des Français est totale.
C'est une spirale finalement
qui ne s'arrête plus.
C'est très pratique puisque finalement,
à bon prix en quelque sorte,
Le régime sait exactement ce que pensent
les Français à tel moment.
Difficile de mesurer l'impact réel
du travail d'espionnage du S.C.T,
sur la politique de Vichy.
Mais au fil des mois, il semble bien
qu'au lieu de rassurer Philippe Pétain,
les notes de synthèse suscitent
chez lui une certaine fébrilité.
Le renseignement est pour
un décideur une drogue dure.
À partir du moment
où vous avez pris l'habitude,
de nourrir votre prise de décision par
du renseignement de diverses sources,
il est très difficile de remettre en cause
ce flot et ce flux d'informations,
Parce que vous considérez
que c'est un des éléments,
de votre prise de décision
éminemment stratégique.
C'est ainsi que Pétain
est de plus en plus contrarié,
par les retours négatifs
que lui font le S.C.T,
sur son bras droit, Pierre Laval.
Les synthèses le décrivent
comme très impopulaire.
"Le Président Laval,
rarement évoqué par ailleurs,
demeure en butte à l'antipathie
violente de la classe ouvrière."
Pierre Laval qui cumule les tares,
il est considéré comme un vendu,
comme un homme corrompu,
comme un opportuniste
et comme un collaborateur.
Les Français le trouvent trop dur
et n'ont pas confiance en lui.
Pétain craint que l'image désastreuse
du vice président du Conseil,
ne rejaillissent sur lui.
Il décide donc de le débarquer.
Le 9 février 1941, l'amiral Darlan
arrive à la tête du gouvernement.
Ce militaire de carrière était déjà
secrétaire d'État à la Marine,
dans le premier gouvernement Pétain.
Il veut pousser plus loin la collaboration
avec le troisième Reich.
Avec Darlan, le S.C.T va prendre
un nouveau visage,
pour devenir une arme redoutable
entre les mains du régime.
Car très vite,
François Darlan a une idée.
Imaginez, vous êtes au pouvoir et vous
avez cet extraordinaire instrument,
qu'est le service des contrôles
techniques qui ouvre...
Des milliers, des centaines
de milliers de lettres,
voire des millions.
La tentation est forte,
puisque vous êtes
un pouvoir autoritaire,
de ce dire, il faut utiliser ses
renseignements pour la répression,
c'est à dire les transmettre
aux multiples services de police,
qui existent sous le régime de Vichy.
Les interceptions permettant de mettre
la main sur des auteurs d'infractions,
sont envoyées à des inspecteurs de police
afin qu'ils déclenchent des enquêtes.
Sont visés tous ceux
qui commettent de petits délits.
À commencer par les Français
qui pratiquent le marché noir,
et des trafics en tout genre.
Pour de tout autres raisons, les femmes
qui ont recours à l'avortement,
sont également dans
le collimateur du régime.
Car Pétain cherche à séduire
les catholiques traditionalistes.
Il a besoin de leur soutien.
Pour cela, il doit leur donner des gages.
La lutte contre l'avortement en est un.
L'avortement était interdit
en France et sous Vichy,
cela devient un crime absolu
au nom de la devise,
Travail, famille, patrie.
Et l'avortement en France
est passible de la peine de mort.
À cause de leur correspondance,
toutes ces personnes qui enfreignent
la loi vont pouvoir être arrêtés.
Les identifier est un jeu d'enfant.
La plupart des lettres sont signées
et les adresses indiquées.
Avec les écoutes téléphoniques,
c'est un peu plus compliqué.
Mais les contrôles techniques
parviennent régulièrement,
à démasquer les correspondants
qui se trahissent en donnant leur nom,
au cours des conversations.
Grâce à toutes ces informations,
Darlan transforme les contrôles techniques
en auxiliaires des services de police.
Pour ne pas griller cette source
de renseignements prodigieuse,
l'amiral met au point
un système diabolique.
Il exige que l'origine
des renseignements permettant,
de déclencher des enquêtes
policières demeure secrète.
Différentes circulaires expliquent que les
documents ne doivent pas sortir du S.C.T,
dans leur forme originale.
Mais seulement après avoir
été démarqués et transformés,
en renseignements de sources sûres,
d'origine inconnue.
Grâce à cette fourberie,
les contrôles techniques sont protégés.
En gros, jamais on ne doit savoir
que les enquêtes sont diligentées,
sur un renseignement qui vient
du service des contrôles techniques.
Systématiquement, il faudra écrire
une petite phrase du genre,
de source sûre, j'apprends que...
"De source sûre",
une formule magique
pour les contrôles techniques,
mais un cauchemar pour les Français
inquiétés par la justice.
Tous ceux arrêtés suite à un renseignement
fourni par le S.C.T,
sont dans une situation
dramatique pour se défendre.
Ce qui est terrible avec le S.C.T,
lorsqu'une personne était
interrogée par la police,
on ne pouvait jamais
lui faire connaître les sources.
Pour un avocat,
il est quasiment,
très difficile de remonter les sources
et de défendre un coupable.
C'est digne d'une justice infernale,
qui ne permet quasiment aucune défense,
aucun appel possible de la part
de celui qui est incriminé.
Malgré tout le zèle qu'ils mettent
à faire régner l'ordre en zone sud,
Darlan déplaît aux Allemands.
Ils le jugent trop mou.
L'amiral ne collaborait pas
assez étroitement avec eux.
Les nazis imposent le retour de Laval,
en qui ils ont toute confiance.
Cette fois, le chef du gouvernement
ne revient pas seul.
Dès son arrivée, le 18 avril 1942,
Laval nomme René Bousquet,
secrétaire général de la police,
et au maintien de l'ordre.
À 33 ans, le plus jeune préfet de France,
est un spécialiste du renseignement.
Bousquet, c'est un flic jeune
mais déjà très expérimenté.
Il a commencé dans les années 30-36.
C'est un spécialiste
des fichiers et des écoutes,
et il va immédiatement donner
aux services des contrôles techniques,
une importance et une puissance
qu'il n'avait jamais eu.
Sous l'impulsion de Bousquet, le S.C.T,
va devenir une machine
au service de la répression.
Cette fois, il ne s'agit plus
de traquer des délinquants,
mais tous ceux que Vichy
considère comme ses ennemis.
Et en ce printemps 42,
ils sont devenus nombreux.
Plus le régime est collaborateur,
réactionnaire, xénophobe et clérical,
plus une partie de l'opinion
lui tourne le dos.
Avec Bousquet au contrôle technique,
les ouvertures de lettres se multiplient.
En plus des interceptions aléatoires,
certaines sont désormais ciblées.
Elles visent tous ceux que le régime
soupçonne de lui être hostiles.
Et en priorité les fonctionnaires,
y compris les gendarmes et les policiers.
À cause d'une malheureuse petite phrase,
certains sont écartés et envoyés dans
des camps d'internement administratifs.
Ces camps qui parsèment la zone libre
sont les prisons politiques du régime.
C'est donc une mesure administrative.
Il n'y a pas de procès, il n'y a
pas de procédure judiciaire.
On met à l'écart,
dans un endroit surveillé,
un individu qui est considéré comme
dangereux pour la sécurité nationale.
Tous ceux qui gênent le régime sont
neutralisés aussi longtemps,
que Pétain, Laval et Bousquet
l'estiment nécessaire.
Mais plus que les fonctionnaires, il y a
un autre ennemi qui obsède le pouvoir.
Les juifs.
Avec la Révolution nationale,
ils sont accusés de tous les maux
et bannis de la société.
Les Juifs n'ont plus le droit
d'exercer certaines professions,
comme celle d'enseignant ou de journaliste.
Leurs biens leur sont confisqués.
À cet antisémitisme purement vichyste
s'ajoute celui des nazis.
Hitler, dans sa folie,
veut éradiquer tous les Juifs d'Europe.
Les déportations ont déjà commencé.
À partir du début de l'année 42,
le dictateur nazi exige cette fois,
des quotas de juifs à livrer de la part
de tous les pays européens qui l'occupe.
La France à elle seule, est sommée
de livrer 40 000 juifs au plus vite.
Les Allemands font de ces arrestations
une priorité parce qu'ils travaillent,
pour reprendre la formule consacrée
dans la direction du Führer,
et que la destruction des Juifs d'Europe
constitue une priorité du régime.
Officiellement, il s'agit de déporter les
Juifs dans des camps de travail en Pologne.
Vichy accepte de coopérer de bonne grâce.
Le régime voit là l'occasion de prouver
aux Allemands sa bonne foi collaboratrice.
Le 2 juillet 42,
Bousquet rencontre Carl Oberg,
le chef suprême de la SS en France,
afin de s'entendre avec lui
sur une manière de procéder.
Les accords Bousquet-Oberg fixent
les modalités de déportation des juifs,
de la zone libre.
Au nom de la souveraineté de Vichy,
il est prévu que la police
et la gendarmerie française,
procèdent elles mêmes aux arrestations.
Mais arrêter 40 000 personnes
n'est pas chose facile.
Si depuis 1940, les juifs devaient s'inscrire
sur des listes de recensement,
beaucoup ne l'ont pas fait.
Comment les repérer ?
Depuis que les arrestations
se multiplient, ils se cachent.
Bousquet va alors sortir l'atout
qu'il a caché dans sa manche.
Il va utiliser les contrôles techniques
pour traquer les juifs.
Et c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit
que le S.C.T est efficace,
à retrouver certains juifs cachés.
Ça permet de repérer des caches,
notamment dans les milieux ruraux,
par exemple dans la Vienne,
dans le Cher, dans les Cévennes.
Beaucoup de Juifs ignorent que leurs
conversations sont surveillées.
Au téléphone ou par écrit,
ils s'épanchent.
Ils ont peur, veulent fuir
et cherchent des solutions.
Leur conversation, souvent déchirante,
témoigne de leur folle détresse.
"Nous vivons dans un cauchemar constant.
Nous sommes cachés quelque part.
Fritz là, moi ici.
Le petit Freddy ailleurs, car on cherche
les Juifs pour les déporter en Pologne.
Chaque jour, chaque nuit,
chaque heure peut amener l'irréparable.
Je vous supplie de nous aider."
"C'est probablement ma dernière
lettre de cebmonde.
Au moment où ces lignes arriveront
en votre possession, nous serons déjà...
Dieu seul le sait.
Les déportations en Pologne sont
déjà mises à exécution dans les parages.
À partir de ces interceptions,
des listes de juifs cherchant
à fuir la France,
sont établies par la police.
Celle-ci date du 2 septembre 1942
et fait froid dans le dos.
Elle répertorie tous les juifs des environs
de Toulouse essayant de quitter la France.
Joseph Pergel, cultivateur,
ne se trouve plus en sécurité,
et cherche à aller dans la Loire.
Madame Weisman s'est échappée avec ses
enfants et se trouve actuellement à Grenoble.
76 000 juifs ont été déportés de France
vers les camps de la mort nazis.
Pour l'essentiel, ils ont été
raflés par la police française.
Certains survivants n'ont jamais
compris comment ils avaient été repérés.
Je pense souvent au retour de la guerre où
certaines familles sont retournées chez elles,
et ont pu penser pendant des années
que le voisin du dessus du dessous,
a pu les dénoncer, alors que
ce n'était pas le cas.
La plupart des dénoncés ne savaient
pas d'où venait la dénonciation.
Peut être ont ils eux-même fourni
les informations pour être dénoncés.
Mais le bilan aurait pu être
beaucoup plus lourd.
Si au sein des PTT,
certains n'avaient pas réagi.
Face aux rafles
comme toute la population,
les postiers sont choqués.
Quand on voit ces groupe de gens
avec leurs petites valises,
on ne sait pas qu'ils vont être gazés.
On ne sait pas le meurtre de masse.
Mais quitter sa famille,
son pays, ses voisins, ses amis,
les gens ont été pleins
de pitié, de compassion,
et d'empathie pour les juifs alors
que jusqu'alors ils étaient indifférents.
Dans certains bureaux de poste,
des filières pour sauver
des juifs se constituent.
C'est le cas
au 103 rue de Grenelle à Paris.
C'est ici que travaille Georges M****.
Sa mission : Fabriquer des cartes
professionnelles pour les agents des PTT.
Ces cartes sont une occasion
inespérée de sauver des juifs.
Comme toute l'administration, les PTT ont
dû se plier aux lois de Vichy.
Depuis 1940, les juifs n'ont plus
le droit de travailler à la poste.
Aux yeux des forces de l'ordre, posséder
une carte professionnelle des PTT,
revient donc à prouver
que l'on n'est pas juif.
Une couverture formidable.
Grâce à son réseau, Georges M****,
récupère des photos de juifs
cherchant à fuir.
Il leur invente des noms et leur fabrique
de fausses cartes d'agent des postes.
J'ai du en faire à peu près ou voler...
300 que j'ai donnée à mon responsable,
qui lui les a donnés à des réseaux juifs.
Au sein de cette résistance PTT,
il y a eu effectivement
un nombre assez important,
d'éléments qui sont restés dans l'ombre.
Ces gens là,
c'était les soutiers de la gloire,
comme on a l'habitude de le dire,
quand on parle de ces anonymes
ou de ces petites mains de la résistance,
et qui ont eu un rôle dont il faut parler,
parce qu'on les a peut être
un peu oubliés et c'est bien dommage.
Au fil des mois, la résistance dans les PTT
devient de plus en plus active.
Vols de lettres de dénonciations,
sabotages de câbles téléphoniques,
ou écoutes de lignes allemandes,
les opérations se multiplient.
À partir de la fin de l'année 1942,
cette résistance s'intensifie encore,
car des évènements extérieurs
changent la donne,
et accélère le tempo.
8 novembre 42,
les troupes anglo-américaines
débarquent en Afrique du Nord.
C'est l'opération Torch.
Des hommes de la France libre
sont là eux aussi.
Ils ont rejoint de Gaulle pour
continuer le combat contre les nazis.
Ils se battent aux côtés des alliés.
En quelques jours, le Maroc et l'Algérie.
basculent dans le camp du monde libre.
Un coup dur pour les Allemands.
En représailles, ils franchissent
la ligne de démarcation.
Désormais, il n'y a plus
ni zone libre, ni zone nord.
Les nazis imposent leur loi.
Ils se souviennent parfaitement
de l'existence du S.C.T.
Et à présent qu'ils contrôlent
tout le territoire,
les Allemands ne souhaitent pas laisser
pareil outil entre les mains de Vichy.
Ils craignent que le S.C.T puisse se
retourner contre eux en les espionnant.
Les nazis interdisent
alors au contrôle technique,
d'effectuer des écoutes téléphoniques.
Laval proteste, mais il doit s'incliner.
Le chef du gouvernement
est même contraint d'accepter,
que des militaires du troisième Reich,
s'installent dans des centraux
téléphoniques et écoutent les Français,
à la place du S.C.T.
Pour le courrier, en revanche, les Allemands
laissent les contrôles techniques opérés.
Toutes les synthèses et les interceptions
susceptibles de les intéresser,
sont transmises aux nazis.
Elles leur permettent de savoir ce qui
se trame et d'arrêter des opposants.
La seule raison,
pour laquelle les Allemands ont laissé
les contrôles techniques subsister,
c'est parce qu'ils bénéficiaient
de leur travail.
Sinon, jamais les Allemands
ne les auraient laissé travailler.
La collusion entre Vichy
et les nazis est totale.
Pendant près de deux ans,
les contrôles techniques continuent
de fonctionner secrètement.
Et partagent leurs informations
avec les Allemands.
Mais en 1944, un événement inattendu,
va venir mettre à mal la belle mécanique
mise en place par les vichystes.
18 mois après avoir mis
le pied en Afrique du Nord,
les Alliés débarquent en Normandie.
Semaine après semaine,
ils reconquièrent le territoire.
Sentant le vent tourner,
certains agents du S.C.T
retournent leur veste.
Ils décident d'entrer dans la résistance.
Secrètement, ils volent alors
des notes de synthèse,
et les font parvenir au général de Gaulle.
Comme Pétain en son temps, le chef
de la France libre est conquis.
Il comprend immédiatement tout
l'intérêt des contrôles techniques,
qui lui permettent de sonder les esprits.
À chaque fois qu'une ville
est libérée par les alliés,
De Gaulle demande à ses hommes
d'investir les contrôles techniques.
De Gaulle voit cet outil
qui a été monté par Darlan,
par Pétain, par Bousquet,
et dit que c'est un outil extraordinaire,
donc on garde tout le monde,
on garde le système,
on met simplement à la tête
des gens de chez nous,
et on va même embaucher.
Alors que le régime de Vichy se disloque,
le général de Gaulle récupère une à une
les commissions de contrôle du S.C.T.
Tout le maillage du territoire et le savoir
faire de Vichy en matière d'espionnage,
est mis au service de la France libre.
Par un ultime affront,
le S.C.T va même se retourner
contre les vichystes,
et permettre de les traquer à leur tour.
Car à l'heure où les nazis sont en
passe de perdre la guerre,
de nombreux collabos
se font passer pour gaullistes.
Le S.C.T va permettre de les démasquer.
Pendant toute la fin de la guerre
jusqu'à l'armistice du 8 mai 1945.
Les gaullistes utilisent
ainsi allègrement le S.C.T.
Une utilisation lourde de conséquences,
car jamais il n y aura d épuration.
Après la libération, les agents
du S.C.T ne seront pas inquiétés.
On ne peut pas les poursuivre
puisque ce serait,
mettre au jour l'existence d'un service
que les gaullistes ont continué d'utiliser,
que les Français libres ont continué
d'utiliser sans aucune publicité bien sûr,
et de façon totalement clandestine.
Et c'est pour ça qu'aussi bien
pour la justice que pour les historiens,
le service des contrôles techniques
est devenu le véritable inconnu,
la pièce manquante
qui n'a jamais été étudiée.
Voilà comment les contrôles techniques sont
tombés dans les oubliettes de l'histoire.
Heureusement, après la guerre,
tous les documents n'ont pas été détruits.
Ceux qui subsistent
aux Archives nationales,
ont permis de reconstituer un puzzle,
et de comprendre comment
le S.C.T a fonctionné.
Traditionnellement utilisé par
les militaires pour contrôler le courrier,
la censure postale est devenu
un instrument diabolique,
entre les mains de Philippe Pétain.
Avec le S.C.T, le Maréchal a su tout
ce qui se tramait dans le pays.
Il a aussi abreuvé les services
de police d'informations,
leur permettant de faire arrêter
des opposants et des juifs.
Après la guerre, les contrôles techniques
n'ont jamais réellement disparu.
À l'automne 1945, ils ont été rattachés
au service des Renseignements généraux.
Ils ont continué à fonctionner
de manière ponctuelle, sous différents noms.
Au cours de la cinquième République.